in this video I'll demonstrate my
technique for creating a vertical
nightmarish visual Loop for a hard rock
band
[Music]
hi my name is Cameron and I am the
creator of motion science before we get
started I wanted to invite you to join
my complimentary workshop at
motionscience.tv Workshop where I unveil
my personal techniques and hidden gems
that I use in my daily workflows this is
a free workshop and takes about 30
minutes so don't miss out on this chance
to level up your skills and make sure to
visit
motionscience.tv Workshop after watching
this video you will not regret it okay
in this video I'm going to demonstrate a
method for designing a visual Loop for a
hard rock band to be used in music
streaming apps like Spotify these short
video Loops often accompany the audio
and can be used for any genre of music
with a darker aesthetic my first step in
creating a visual Loop is selecting the
footage in a real life project the
artist would provide the footage but for
demonstration purposes I need to find
some suitable footage I use art grid a
stock footage website to search for
keywords such as dark Sinister scary and
Wicked This allows me to find footage
that immediately strikes me as being
perfect for the project I download a
couple of options to work with and
import them into After Effects since
Spotify Loops are a vertical format I
set my composition to 1080 by 1920 and
then I focus on positioning and scaling
the footage to give me the best possible
composition once I have the footage in
place I will begin to add visual effects
and layer them to create a unique and
visually striking Loop that perfectly
captures the dark and Sinister tone of
the band to enhance the composition and
give it an unpleasant energy I can add
camera Shake I can achieve this by using
a simple wiggle expression and turning
on motion blur alternatively I can also
use plugins from companies like red
giant which give me more control over
the overall look of the camera Shake
next I add an adjustment layer that is
bigger than the composition this is to
create a blur effect on the footage in
After Effects there are many blur
effects to choose from but in this
project I choose the channel blur effect
as it allows me to affect only specific
color channels giving the piece an
ethereal look I then add a mask with a
high feather amount so that I am only
blurring parts of the image I also add a
wiggle expression to the position of the
adjustment layer this is why I made the
adjustment layer larger than the
composition so that the layer can move
around the comp without revealing the
sides of the Mask these techniques will
create a unique and disturbing visual
effect that perfectly captures the
nightmarish feel of the song to further
add to the uneasy feeling of the
composition I'll add the Optics
compensation effect this effect will add
another layer of unsettling imagery to
the composition to the Optics
compensation effect I add two wiggle
Expressions one is added to the field of
view and another is added to the View
Center these wiggle Expressions create
Dynamic and unpredictable movement
adding to the nightmarish feel of the
song I also add a color adjustment layer
for color adjustments I will typically
use the lumetri color effect that is
built into after effects or sometimes I
like to use a third-party effect like
magic bullet looks which has some really
interesting color look presets that
deliver impressive results quickly
however I don't usually use a preset
straight out of the box it's always a
good idea to make minor adjustments and
it's usually a good idea to reduce the
overall strength of the look to make it
more subtle and natural lastly I add one
more adjustment layer over the top of
everything else and to this adjustment
layer I add the posterize time effect
this effect gives the composition a more
Steppy look by reducing the number of
frames per second I adjust the settings
for the effect to around 12 to 18 frames
per second to achieve the look I
envisioned for this project this Final
Touch gives the composition a unique and
unsettling feel that perfectly captures
the nightmarish atmosphere of the band
and there you have it my process for
creating a nightmarish Spotify loop I
hope this was both informative and
entertaining for you and if you enjoy
the video please hit the like button and
consider subscribing to my YouTube
channel for more content just like this
your support means the world to me and
helps me continue creating content I
would love to hear your thoughts on the
video so please leave a comment or
question below and as always thank you
so much for watching and I look forward
to connecting with you in my next video
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]